there are new questions today about why
a North Carolina
teenager who was violently arrested
during what his mother says was a mental
health emergency received a plea deal
instead of the treatment he was seeking
yesterday we showed you video of Hayden
long being tackled to the ground tased
and then punched while in handcuffs
after his mother tried to take him to a
hospital ER Janet shamlian is outside
that hospital in Lincolnton North
Carolina Janet why did the teenager take
the plea Anthony good morning Hayden's
mom Jessica says he took that plea deal
to avoid being tried as an adult on the
felony assault charge now the incident
is raising questions about how people
with potential mental health issues
should be treated and cared for an
expert saying that Hayden should have
been met with help not handcuffs
Hayden long pleaded guilty in juvenile
court Monday to two misdemeanor charges
one for assault the other underage
drinking because the alternative was
letting my sixteen-year-old son go to
court as an adult this was the easiest
and the safest route to take it came
after this incident outside the North
Carolina hospital where his mom had
taken him for help
believing he was having a mental
breakdown security video shows Hayden
spitting blood on deputy Justin Polson
who responded by punching the 16
year-old in the head Hayden was
handcuffed at the time in court Monday
deputy Polson said he was no longer with
the Sheriff's Department it's not known
if he was fired for his actions he
testified he didn't believe the teen
needed mental health treatment at the
time Hayden's mom defended her son's
behavior mental illness displays in a
lot of different ways well maybe he
drank the alcohol because he is mentally
ill he is suffering from something else
and trying to self-medicate the video
showing hospital security guards and
sheriff's deputies responding with force
is alarming to Angela Kimball with the
National Alliance on Mental Illness when
parents take their child to the
emergency department
they're expecting hell
not handcuffs children like Hayden
deserved treatment and safety and he got
neither Kimble says hospitals and first
responders need to know how to
de-escalate these situations trained
mental health professionals know that
people's behaviors can be very agitated
that's one thing we have to recognize
otherwise we end up harming people in
court Hayden told the judge he was
taking antidepressants at the time his
mother says she hopes the incident will
be a wake-up call not just for parents
but also for law enforcement the family
has not decided whether to pursue legal
action Gale who Janet that video is
tough to watch thank you very much
I see the tough spot the mother's into
because she clearly thinks that
behaviors egregious and looking at on
the tape it does seem to be so you also
don't want to put your son like that at
16 yeah very tough spot but taken you
don't feel he's guilty